you said you're on a dating app so how
is dating then
in quarantine going really
not great
it's not it's i'm feel more single than
ever
but it's fine i want your hot
throbbing
[Music]
i want to start with this new movie a
nice girl like you to kind of set it up
for the people out there
it's about a girl who's dating this guy
and he breaks up with her
calls her pornophobic she kind of goes
on this
sexual exploration of her own so what
was it about this subject that kind of
drew
you in for me like the whole time
reading it i was like
i'm so uncomfortable which made me i was
like i have to do it
because that told me a lot of other
people
are still uncomfortable about this topic
because women
aren't supposed to be this person but we
are we can be
sexual and we can be open about being
sexual it's not just the men that's
ridiculous that's so like
1960s we're in 2020 we should embrace
who we are and we should embrace our
sexuality because that's like
so much of who we are how we express
ourselves how we are in relationships
and you know this movie is more on the
nose but like
of like let's go to a strip club let's
go do all these things
but the takeaway should be own whoever
it is that you are whoever it is that
you love
own it just admit you're not into sex
it's kind of like you're pornophobic
try saying something racing you need to
decide
it's me or the porn
did you at all talk to some of your
girlfriends or even some of your guy
friends
about this like did you research
anything i kind of because my character
was supposed to be like
slightly in the dark and slightly
uncomfortable i was like
i am too i'm just gonna like roll with
the punches because
um there were a lot of things on that
list that i hadn't done like we went to
an actual sex convention
which was whoa like
so yeah and it was so cool to see people
just
completely comfortable with who they
were you know because we can all be
super judgmental about
people in that industry and it's like i
commend them they're just like
free i wish i could be that free um
so as far as research i kind of just
went with it you know
quick question for you do you do pilates
or
oh wow do you hope that this movie helps
to get people
talking about i mean porn strip clubs
more so
like normalizing it like what what do
you hope that conversation yeah i mean
more so just like
if you don't want to talk about it don't
talk about it but i think that we are
so at least as women trained to think
that we need to keep that
a part of our private life which if you
want to that's totally fine but
it should be normalized and it should um
empower you it shouldn't embarrass you
we do see your character who's also
named lucy
lucy neil lucy hale honey
meet this great guy but not without a
few hiccups
what is your most embarrassing dating
story in real life
do you have one i've it's so crazy
because all the people i've dated
we already like knew each other so i
haven't really done the classic
meet you for the first time dating
experience
like ever in my life i'm on like a
dating site now and i've still never met
up with any of them because i'm too
nervous
um wait no i just can't like all the
people i've dated i've already known
them because
i'm so shy believe it or not i'm like
really shy in that sense
um i'm like do you feel like that's
because you're in hollywood and it's
you have to be wary of people who might
have ulterior
motives i feel like you're such a catch
oh thank you you're very sweet i i think
i i guess i'm just like expecting
someone to come knock on my door like i
just don't put myself out there
but i think it's part of like my job
plays into it but i'm just
yeah i'm a shy person i guess you said
you're on a dating app so how is dating
then
in quarantine going really
not great
it's not it's it's i'm feel more single
than ever
but it's fine i mean i think if anything
during this time
it's taught us because i've done the
whole thing basically alone
and i used to hate like being alone and
this i feel
the only way i'm gonna date someone next
is if they make my life better because
i'm so
happy right now being having my own
routine
i met someone so i made a sex to-do list
best breakup ever your character is such
a list maker
so are there qualities that you actually
look for
in a person besides just making your
life better oh yes
i mean i'm really not because i don't i
physically do not have a type i've dated
everything across the board um my sense
of humor is
yeah anything to me and i have a very
specific sense of humor
uh that someone who's just like
confident and comfortable in their skin
there's so many
insecure men out there and it's i can't
do that i've dated that don't want that
um uh work ethic
like drive passion about i don't care
what you do just like
love it and yeah i think 110
um like a good moral compass just be a
good person
it's very simple what i'm looking for
but that's hard the simple qualities are
actually harder to find
which is so sad when you think about it
yes it is
yes lacy's is closing you guys and i
have just been offered
the opportunity of a lifetime i do want
to talk about katie keane
really fast i was very bummed because
also we had just talked about
your hopes for season two and you guys
left off on this cliffhanger
are there chances that it could get
picked up somewhere
else like are there conversations
happening about that i think
maybe but i think because of where we're
at in the world
and i i i'm not getting my hopes up
about it because
i don't i i don't see that happening
unfortunately knock on wood maybe
um so i've kind of you know i was sad
about it for a week i'm still sad about
it but like i was really sad about it
for a week
um and i made my piece with it and i was
like get it together lucy you had a
great time
nothing will take away from what i
consider a really great season and
i would rather do one awesome season
that people loved than do like six that
people are like oh god like let it end
already
so i feel i've seriously made peace with
it
just heartbreaking i mean it's a job
that has broken my heart
numerous times this is bad this is a bad
one
that day that i like made that video on
my instagram and was like this is what
happened
i was so flooded with support and love
that
i needed to be reminded of that and it
was amazing
you were very emotional in that video
just what will you miss most about the
show the cast or
yeah yeah but they're still my people
like they're still my
you know that's not going away i miss i
miss new york i really do
i really loved living there yeah i'm
just playing katie i think she
i feel like i was like born to play her
so that's why it was so devastating
because i was like you're just cutting a
life
short what are you doing but not my
decision
i feel like you've been working so
steadily
for so many years in a row i mean even
since
before pll after plo you've just always
like had the next thing
lined up and you do have projects lined
up
after this will you ever just kind of
like take a break
do you feel like now is it time to do
that
i feel like business book this time
during this
pandemic quarantine whatever you call it
um it's the longest time i've ever had
off and i'm just like
itching because i feel my best when i'm
creative and i feel my best when i'm
productive
and there are ways to be that when
you're in your house but it's not the
same
um i love working
i love it more than anything um but i
think maybe when i have kids i'll take a
little bit of time off which that's
the future yeah that's not it
it's funny that you say that though
because we just did a whole entire piece
about the pll cast and sort of growing
up and so
and how so many of you guys have had
kids or have gotten married
is that something that you think about
like everyone's married everyone has a
kid
no there's nothing wrong with that like
everyone's on their own
i'm not even i'm so cool with like i
said i'm not
settling for anything less than what i'm
looking for
um because why why would i
um uh but it is it's it's amazing to see
people having babies on pll and getting
married and
um it's it's nice supporting them from
afar i can't wait to
god atlas is cute atlas is
so cute my mom is more obsessed with
atlas
than probably any she just like
sends me pictures of her i was like i
know mom she's a beautiful child
yeah she's a gorgeous baby yeah but yeah
that is something i want i mean i'll let
it happen organically i'm not like
yeah it'll happen when it happens so yes
what was it like to celebrate your
birthday
amid this pandemic and did you get to do
anything special
i actually safely traveled home to
tennessee
i was like i'm not getting my birthday
in my house so i went my mom lives in
the middle of nowhere in tennessee and
just hung out with the family and like
grilled out and
she got me a pinata it was very sweet
i could have spent four months there but
um hopefully soon
because i have two little nieces and a
nephew and i oh
birthdays tattooed on me before i let
you go let's go back to the movie why do
you think
people should watch this film first of
all it's so silly and a blast
and like it is so light-hearted like we
need that right now i think it's coming
out at the perfect time
but also uh like we were talking about
earlier it's just a topic
that might make people a little
uncomfortable but like
just go with it sink into it um it's
something
we all do we all talk about it's such a
big part of who we are
and i hope for women i hope it makes
them
feel great about themselves and empowers
them and
uh i think men will enjoy
[Music]